Now let's turn to feedback. How would you let a user know
when something was done? How does the user know that the action has
been completed? So now, now you're going to do the exchange. So
now you're exchanging with someone. How do you know when it's been completed?
>> Okay.
>> You know what's funny about these questions, is they seem obvious. Like,
duh, right, but actually when you're the designer, you have to think about this.
>> Yeah.
>> What happens that shows it's done?
>> Mhm.
>> The numbers change. Does anything else happen?
Do they see the numbers change? If you view
this like some Apple products sometimes, like when
you delete something, the little piece moves into the
trash can. You know, that's feedback. Right? But
it's also feedback that showed what happened. Like this
thing didn't just disappear, it moved into this
other folder that you can actually go to. [SOUND]